let's shift to ufos speaking of things
that only conspiracy theorists used to
talk about that now we all talk about uh
barack obama former president barack
obama who i assume the progressives will
call the races soon enough well he he
mentioned some stuff about ufos let's
take a listen
there's footage and records of
objects in the skies that we
don't know exactly what they are we
can't explain
uh
how they moved
their trajectory people still take
seriously trying to investigate and
figure out what that is
there's a whole fleet of look on the sa
okay so there's been more and more ufo
footage over the last couple of months
being leaked out there's more and more
you know seemingly credible people
talking about it i gotta tell you guys
this is literally the first time i've
mentioned it on this show and i thought
that in and of itself tells you sort of
where we're at in the world that if
aliens had landed last week i'm not sure
i would have mentioned it because
there's so much other craziness going on
uh cabot you're very excited about this
ufo situation
i have loved this i mean this has been
one of the trending stories all month on
our website too i think our readers are
really into it i think average americans
a lot of people are saying for years we
were called crazy if we asked any
questions about ufos and now all of a
sudden we've got the former president of
the united states we've got former
defensive officials and intelligence
officials and navy admirals coming out
saying yeah there's something out there
we have no clue what it is i think the
three biggest likelihoods right now
number one is just that it's the united
states government that it's something
going on we've denied that it's us for
all these sightings that we're seeing
but the timing does seem weird there's
all this stuff going on in the world and
then they all of a sudden decide to say
oh yeah there are these unidentified
aerial phenomena we don't know about
here's all this footage to look at the
timing seems weird there so i think
that's probably the most likely it could
be something alien i don't really know
but also
china i just find it hard to believe
that this is china that all these craft
we're seeing in china the first footage
that we have here is in 2004 long before
china's new tech boom their aircraft
carriers their submarines are archaic
compared to the united states and for
that technology not to manifest itself
elsewhere in their military and also for
the chinese not to brag about it they
brag at every opportunity they get about
their new technology developments so i
just don't think it's china at this
point i think it's either the united
states or it's something else but i just
find it hard to believe it's china if it
is that's a lot scarier than it being
aliens in my opinion for the record i've
spent enough nights stoned watching
ancient aliens to know that it's the
lizard people but liz liz you're a woman
of facts you like facts you like data
you like researching things ufos i
bridge too far
that was a really great tee up for this
is the least sexy take on ufos that
you're ever gonna hear first of all
barack obama's opinion on this means
nothing to me the title of his like 6
000 page memoir should be trouble
recognizing reality so just because he
can't recognize this means absolutely
nothing to me
the most likely explanation for this the
most likely explanation is something
called parallax which is essentially
visual distortion when objects of
different speeds are traveling towards
each other and then through camera
lenses there i mean that's literally the
most likely explanation for this kind of
stuff but they're appearing on radar
so wouldn't if there was a visual
distortion why would they appear on
radar
you can have other objects so for
example there i think there's like three
black and white grainy videos that are
sort of forming the foundation of this
one of them shows something diving
towards the water and then skidding
along the water without appearing to
decelerate right well if you take
parallax into account and i'm no expert
on this this is just what i read it
seems to me the most plausible theory uh
it actually is the shape the size and
has the ability the same as a canadian
goose
so
i think first of all there are plausible
explanations the other thing is the
context of the classification as ufo or
unidentified aerial phenomena it
actually doesn't mean that it was never
identified it means that when the pilot
saw it their immediate reaction was they
couldn't immediately identify it so it
doesn't actually mean that these
continued to be unidentified they just
had that classification initially so i
think the more realistic explanations
are things like birds and things like
commercial airliners that were out of
focus that were distorted by parallax
but i could be wrong probably not but i
might be i love that the new divide in
the conservative world will be whether
little green men actually exist marlow
what do you think i'm the hardest hit by
this because for me i was 100 convinced
aliens were here they were living among
us mathematically maybe one of you guys
were aliens i'm just trying to trying to
be logical here in mathematics but now
that barack obama and joe biden are on
the ufos i'm 100 convinced they're not
here we're alone in the universe we'll
never discover anything else and i'm so
disappointed i was in tears i was in a
heap but in all honesty this does feel
like a a big distraction there's a lot
of problems going on in this country uh
middle east is on fire right now the
border is open and people are flooding
through it and now we're talking lab
leak stuff it's a the jobs numbers are
not where they should be the energy
sector is not where it should be and now
we're talking aliens it seems like a
total head fake by the government and um
it's fun but it's it's stupid hour yeah
the cabinet to that point you just
mentioned that a lot of your readers are
into this stuff
does that sort of tell you that people
are kind of like broken by politics the
stuff alex just mentioned like people
kind of can't take this endless grind
that's sort of why i wanted to do this
story with you guys because there was
obviously a plenty of stuff we could
have talked about about the middle east
or anything else this week and i was
like ah people do need like a little bit
of a silly break every now and again
i do think that's the case i actually
went out and filmed a man on the street
video like this yesterday on in downtown
nashville i talked about 50 people very
anecdotal but of all those people the
number one response was i don't trust
the government yeah it was people on the
left and right people were saying look
this could be aliens those videos are
pretty scary it's kind of wild that
they're appearing on infrared and radar
and it's not just you know some all this
only grainy stuff but at the end of the
day they're like the government after
all this year i don't really trust him
on anything and i think that's where a
lot of people are and i do think a big
part of it is it's fun we've all been
locked in for the last year and a half
and we've all only ever heard kind of
fringe people talking about these things
and so now to get to hear these
legitimate senators and intelligence
members and navy admirals and commanders
and things coming forward saying these
things it does add an extra layer of
intrigue where they're now saying wait a
second it's no longer crazy i can talk
about it more and i do think a lot of
it's just fun for people yeah does this
mean alex jones can
does this mean alex jones can get back
on youtube
oh yeah i'm sure they're i'm sure
they're reinstating the account at any
moment now but that's that's really
interesting to me what you said there
cabin this idea that most people their
answer came down to not whether aliens
exist but i don't trust the government
and i i mentioned before and i know you
guys are all on board on this and alex
you just wrote a book about it the lack
of trust in media and it seems to me liz
like that's the biggest issue right now
we don't have trusted sources to the
point that people try to i suppose seek
out people like us but we're just people
too who can only you know siphon through
the information that we're given
right and i think building on cabot's
point a little bit too that people don't
trust the government but i think it's a
little bit more existential than that
even people are trying to seek something
greater than themselves oftentimes
especially people who aren't
particularly religious and so they're
really fascinated by the idea that there
might be some kind of overlords out
there even even if they're not connected
with us even if they're not our
overlords they're fascinated by the idea
of something greater or something in the
great beyond and so i think that feeds
into it a little bit um as well but yeah
i mean the media doesn't tell the truth
what you do dave and what i do and what
alex and what cabot does i mean what
we're doing is we are sifting through
the facts because so because the
mainstream outlets the corporate outlets
the liberal outlets won't do it that's
that's what i mean that's what we do
even about fun stories we look to see
what is plausible what's not plausible
what's backed up with fact what's
contradicted what's narrative what's not
what's corrupt who's corrupted um and we
present the truth and that's why our
type of media has been so successful
compared to the corporate media